there are over 18 million jobs in the
field of cloud computing globally simply
learns AWS certified solution architect
associate level course will help you
understand the key concepts required to
prepare for the certification exam the
practice assignments and the three live
projects this course comprises of
twenty-four hours of instructor led
training 15 hours of eLearning
over 50 demonstrations to understand
architecting through the AWS console and
you will also be provided with three
question sets totaling 180 questions the
world wide cloud computing market grew
28 percent to 110 billion dollars in
revenues in 2015 in the last quarter of
2015
AWS revenue was up 69 percent
year-on-year
AWS Solutions Architect associate level
is the perfect certification to start
your journey with AWS you'll enhance
your existing knowledge of AWS and will
deepen your understanding of every
product and service that AWS offers you
will learn how to design plan and scale
in the AWS cloud using Amazon
recommended best practices with the
certification you'll be an asset to any
organization helping it to leverage the
benefits of best practices around
advanced cloud-based solutions and
migrate existing workloads to the cloud
whether you're looking to future-proof
for your career or just prove you'll
know how about the leading cloud
provider in the global market becoming
an AWS solutions architect associate
will put you well on your way to
achieving your career goals you can
reach out to our teaching assistant
support staff anytime during the course
and for assistance with projects
candidates can submit their queries that
help and support on our website or they
can get connected with our staff using
simply talk and the live chat options
this concludes the course introduction
and we hope you're all geared up to
begin the AWS Solutions Architect
associate level course
happy learning